pendant six mois alan malony professeur
et chercheur enseignera à lui vécu grâce
à la commission cher fulbright entouré
de professeurs et de scientifiques
l'américain enseignera l'évolution de la
technologie à versailles et dating
gauche sur la lointaine j'enseigne mes
cours en anglais c'est une chose et
aussi pour les cours en master sur les
hautes performances informatiques
j'enseigne dans ce programme aux
étudiants de deuxième année en ce moment
je leur enseigne comment faire une
optimisation des performances sur des
eaux processus son cpu des systèmes
informatiques à la malmö qui enseignent
habituellement dans le département
d'informatique à l'université de
l'oregon restera pour transmettre son
savoir aux étudiants français
un dispositif de collaboration entre les
états unis et la france pour inclure un
professeur étrangers au programme ça
apporte à l'université ben un chercheur
de renommée qui vient pour six mois et
qui peut développer alors il va nous
apporter de manière très intéressante en
termes ce soit en termes d'enseignement
ou de recherche
une autre vision des choses d'une autre
manière tout un réseau grâce à cette
chère le professeur malony et marées par
la suite entreprendre sur le long terme
un partenariat dans la recherche avec
levesque